oh i'm so
very honored and excited to meet you
so nice to meet you as well okay
let's go right to your childhood winnie
okay let's start from the beginning
let's start at the beginning
okay when you were four you were
diagnosed with an autoimmune condition
uh vitiligo and what
was your life like when you were a kid
what was your family like what were your
feelings
who were you at four years old at four
years old
i was a really happy child and
i think that's because my family was so
loving and so supporting
and so they had such a will
to make sure that i felt normal and
felt like my differences
were a very important part of who i was
when i did first get vitiligo my mom was
um
she was worried you know it was
something that she hadn't heard of
before
so i remember her bringing me over to my
grandmother and my aunt and lifting up
the back of my shirt and being like look
there's a new spot on her back
and my grandmother was like you can't do
that to her because she's going to feel
like her differences are something
that's negative
and that's not right she has to grow up
knowing that
all the things that make her her are
valid and are beautiful and that's how
you make her feel important
well i love hearing that too because i
as a parent
am learning on the job i think we
probably
all are and what a blessing that your
grandmother
had such awesome wisdom for your mom
for sure it's so important i think today
especially with social media
and so many outlets for kids to go to to
learn or watch things i think we forget
that the most
important place for children to learn is
at home
what parents teach their kids and
enforcing their kids
is so important well you've been a real
force on social media
and ironically i heard you were sort of
you know
tentative to put yourself out there at
first
and now you're one of the world's
biggest supermodels
what how does it go from like tentative
putting toe in the water
to being one of the most famous
beauties on planet earth it's
true oh thank you i appreciate it no i
i think it was just because it was
something that was new and anything
that's new is kind of scary
but when i realized that people were so
excited about me putting myself out
there and
the the way i felt about myself and how
i felt like i was beautiful
and i wasn't going to let someone else's
opinions get me down
and that encouraged others to do the
same i was like you know what
if it's inspiring for other people let
me continue let me just
be out there because everyone goes
through something
everyone is different which is what
makes us all the same so
i have this thing where like people
always want to be normal but like what
is normal there's this idea of
what normal is but everyone's normal you
have freckles that's normal you have
brown hair that's normal you have green
eyes that's normal you have brown eyes
that's normal
all these things are normal i mean
do you want to have kids because i think
you should be basically a parent to us
all i do want kids
but not right now i mean
i think that when you talk about how we
all have this
shared common experience to hear you
talking about that
i think it i just i look
forward to my daughter's you know
learning and experiencing life through
your eyes and your wisdom
and your words because i think they're
very
calming and healing and yet really
inspiring and energizing at the same
time
i think that's because i don't take
myself too seriously
and i understand that i'm a human like i
don't i always say i don't believe in
role models
i don't believe in putting anyone on a
pedestal to say
this is who i should be like but i do
believe
in pulling inspiration from everyone no
one's perfect
people are going to make mistakes i make
mistakes all the time
and while i love that people pull
inspiration for me i wouldn't want to be
anyone's
like role model or put up on a pedestal
because i know i'm
only human i don't know
winnie i'm getting superhero vibes i'm
hearing superhero wisdoms
even even superheroes have their
kryptonite yes
they absolutely do in fact superheroes
are incredibly flawed
i'm trying to think inside like what my
kryptonite is do you have a kryptonite
uh my kryptonite is maybe
like i'm i'm from the hood so sometimes
i just like to get like real street with
it and just say what's real what's on my
mind
sometimes i need a little filter
sometimes so yeah
not having a filter sometimes is my
kryptonite
i like i like your kryptonite i'm into
your kryptonite
i feel like i want like i want more of
your street no filter
i'm already writing the body language of
it and i'd like to hear what comes out
i'm not gonna lie maybe we can throw
down sometime because i'm like oh i want
in i want some of like winnie's no
filter
yeah come come come to a party with me
and we'll we'll vibe out
well winnie you are making me feel alive
again
i used to go to parties for sure
will you please take me to a party i
have been in
mom mode for so long like
listen and then when i finally have kids
then you can help me out there as well
because i know i'm gonna need tons of
help
yes i can and i too will always be
encouraging
for us to not take ourselves too
seriously
for us to promote strength and humor
and humanity
you